have you heard of huberman husbands the
huberman husbands thing was really about
how a woman was saying that she thinks
she's the huberman husband because she
does all these different things for the
people that don't know the The Meta meme
around huberman husbands is that all of
the wies want is a husband who's into
red light therapy and he does cold
plunges and he does Sauna treatments and
stuff I wondered how you feel of a bunch
of guys potentially cosplaying as Andrew
huberman in the bedroom you now have
people fully laughing as
maybe they're telling their wife that
they didn't get enough sunlight in their
eyes is dirty talk in the bedroom I
don't know what cosplay is and I don't
know what laring is cosplay is dressing
up someone will go as Anakin Skywalker
or Pikachu or whatever Ling live action
role playing there is potentially a
market out there if a guy is struggling
in the dating world to take the
aesthetic get fully huberman pilled and
then there is a huge potential demand
amongst the wives out there